what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn nine nine today John how how
are you I'm walking here I'm ready for
some Brooklyn how we use G doing good
thank you John yeah
you're welcome you should leave a like
for for this intro and be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
maybe check us out on patreon yeah we
got a cat going crazy hat going crazy
right now Casper really wants attention
because they want to eat obnoxiously
early give them to me excuse me
I'll kill you I'll kill you copper in
front of everyone kill you on camera
I'll kill you hey guys full in threat to
watch along as we sync up with your own
copy of Brooklyn nine nine are available
for super sexy rejects those are just
taking too long now because because you
copper is you you don't you don't mess
up this whole intro let's go
I do it once a month we just never been
on the night shift it's like we're being
punished we are we're going to Florida
frankly I pitied a lot of you
I look out there and see an opportunity
I'm gonna slide on that slippery floor
all the way from Holt's office to the
elevator you're gonna do the fbp that's
right Rosa that's right I'm doing the
full bullpen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do it
[Laughter]
it's very satisfying they're
investigating death threats against some
author named DC parlov as if anyone
knows who the hell that is DC Paulo
is
blue windshield author of our time 12
books chronicling the war between sky
and sand clouds and rocks the subsidian
Game of Thrones is a Skyfire type thing
get your head out of here
I spent hours reading those books whoa
little terry did not see that coming
little terry
the sky fire cycle sand into glass the
Reckoning of collar man that is a long
book is the rest of it just more of the
title
listen to the inscription he wrote Terry
you do have friends you have me little
terry wrote his own story yeah a little
terry got buff
oh Terry got emotionally healthy
he didn't get Jack way to go little
terry big back's coming through ah there
we go the little terry on the inside
Terry's gonna meet his hero oh no never
meet your Heroes
[ __ ] check it out our squad has doubled
the number of arrests on the night shift
yeah no one cares oh my God
[Laughter]
um imagine you're on a game show there
are three doors behind one of which is a
car you're telling it wrong there are
three doors behind one of which is a car
now the host asks if you'd like to
choose the other unopened door should
you do it no yes the prize is behind one
of two doors it's a 50 50 chance either
way it's two-thirds if you switch one
third if you don't the probability locks
in when you make the choice which Jesus
Christ ah my brain now you can't even do
simple addition
Kevin is right
the guys at the 9-5 gave us the DC power
case no big deal you don't have to thank
me give it back you're welcome wait what
this is a bad idea Jake I don't want to
meet him why you're nervous to meet your
hero look I get it we need a guest star
come on you're braver than this just
tell them how meaningful the no he wrote
you was people love knowing that they
changed someone's life I mean why do you
think I'm doing this for you this isn't
about me no 30 years ago you won't
remember and I feel silly well we're
about to find out carlov just walked in
oh God oh God oh God oh God oh God don't
just breathe stop calm down little oh my
God Terry
a little curious about why my case got
reassigned is there some problem quite
the opposite the top brass just wanted
New York's best detective on it to allow
me to introduce Mr Sergeant Terry
Jeffords
who might be sending them well I'm
pretty sure that it had to be a fan I've
had a little bit of a backlash from some
of my younger male readers ever since I
revealed the fact that quando the dragon
is actually a female I think teen boys
would love a lady Dragon woke Dragon I
don't know you're the right quandoor is
not a sexual being for she is the Ender
of Bloodlines all Mortals tremble before
her oh Sky fire fan oh I'm more than a
fan whoever wrote this has got nothing
on me yeah he's not a killer oh my I
wrote you a letter telling you how
lonely and sad I was and you sent me a
book with the inscription and it changed
my life I do remember as the cloud Rock
said you found yourself in your struggle
wow the truth wow and you found it
within your stripe Jinx well that was
cool be brave
bus
[Music]
[Laughter]
turns out Sam here also thinks we should
go to Aruba I know it sounds crazy but
the Caribbean might be more fun than
Iowa in what universe
looks like you already got burned oh did
I because my skin still tastes pretty
raw ew sorry oh I'm calling the Council
of the cousins I'm scared just kidding
come on Sam Sam say Sam come downstairs
Sam stay come on Sam son
be your own man Sam purpose local
they'll probably try and strike at the
book reading tomorrow night and he's
probably camped out on the street with
the other Fanboys they've been lined up
for three days do you think he's did it
himself
um maybe
it's a fraud I just need a way to
compare the fans handwriting to the
death threats we get them to sign a
petition to make cuando the dragon a
male ooh s'more but are we gonna fit in
there dress like this no we're not yeah
I guess let's do this dope
oh my God dope Terry Kratos
Condor the Dragon
Dragon
probability doesn't kick in do I have to
teach you college level statistics I
don't know do I have to teach you high
school statistics do I have to teach you
eighth grade statistics do I have to
teach you seventh grade statistics
statistics that early okay we have got
to explain this thing to Captain hold to
save their relationship anyway it's not
about the math they haven't seen each
other because of the night shift it just
need a bone what growth Rosa those are
our dads
I feel a little lame out here I mean
you've got this cool sword and I'm
wearing what potato sack you're my Noble
Squire you should be thankful for that
burlap it's hiding a terrible failed
castration oh my God I hate these books
handeth me John patish Lawless
this is a star you really want parlov to
hear you you're gonna have to send a
message in blood
got a suspect
let's ride oh that's very heavy
got a real sword yeah talk about this
stuff with Sharon no she hates it yeah
it makes sense oh this writing doesn't
match up I'm gonna sit into the lab
anyway yeah I don't think that's
necessary why not because I just found a
perfect match I told you called it wrote
the death threats he sent them to
himself Terry did not see that coming
I did and that is see you're promoted
here rose-colored glasses got in the way
make himself more relevant I know how it
is it can be disappointing to meet your
hero just like me and Patrick Ewing you
said that went great I lied it was a
disaster excuse me my name is
Oh no you're my favorite player
there's no way pauloff sent himself that
death threat we're going to talk to him
and he'll have an explanation whatever
you need screw you Peralta I'm sorry I
thought you were going to disagree thank
you for your support it really means a
lot to me you think you would uh change
his writing okay Santiago no I lost my
ring did you see where it went ah it's
it's behind one of these three
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work when Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life come on Sir the math
thing isn't the problem night shift's
keeping you and Kevin apart you two just
need a bone
how dare you detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer
what happens in my
phone ever speak to me like that again
yeah he needs to um why did you choose
that dude to spin up now he knows
problem solved
but let's still do the doors one long
banana boat with the 15 of us on it
holding each other by the waist having
the time of our damn lives do we really
want to go where Pirates of the
Caribbean took place yes yes we do that
movie gave us nightmares for months
boils are nothing if not loyal loyal to
our favorite brand of peanut butter Mr
nuts loyal to each other
I love you I love you I approve this
message
I love you I love you you guys both did
so good Council adjourned I love you I
love you
Mr parlov did you send yourself those
death threats for publicity are you
kidding me no need for publicity
handwriting and the death threats
matches perfectly with the inscription
you wrote to Terry yeah tell you the
truth I didn't actually write this
inscription oh no I didn't want to piss
you off the man you're looking for he's
my Exorcist Edmund Graham the guy hates
me I slept with his wife so naturally
had to fire him yes naturally natural
having sex with three gorgeous women in
Cosplay well
that went terribly
I am so sorry do you need a moment alone
or you want to talk about it I was
waiting for that oh that's hurtful that
went terribly maybe he won't open the
door and you'll have to kick it down
that always cheers you up I don't feel
like kicking down the door what about
running really fast through a wall
leaving a perfect outline of your body
yes
no the hero I was talking about is you
you're a great cop and dad and husband
and boss also you always smell just a
little bit like vanilla that's my soap I
got it at Lush nice
self-care Terry some stupid book isn't
what made you who you are and it bums me
out that you can't see that now I'm
gonna go get this bad guy
because that's what you taught me to do
also what was the name of the soap store
again
it's the biggest soap store we're all
hurting boils
get that Squeeze Box you even bought
cousin Sherman a scrunchie for his
ponytail yeah so I could win and you did
win Plot In The Family Cemetery all of
us together lying in a grave for
eternity grave singular Oh Captain I
know you don't want to talk about Monty
Hall but I did contact a math professor
no need Santiago it's all good so the
fight with Kevin because you understand
the map nope because you guys yep yep
see what happened is your dad's had sex
okay
NYPD I need to ask you a few questions
about DC parlov oh okay let me just undo
the chain
come on
Terry get him Terry
taste the might of color
we write our own stories so welcome to
the Terry Chronicles book one the arrest
of Edmund Grail followed by book two the
ravishing of Sharon I am so sorry oh
couldn't let you down and that is why
you're my hero come on bring it in Big
Fellas
[Laughter]
oh buddy
poor guy
you gotta Embrace being pants that's
right I remember one time in high school
oh no for the limited time I was there
before I got kicked out
for banging all the students every
student that's why they were like can't
the Temptation is too strong and the
students can't focus Greg
it's not fair to their education and I
said I'll gladly leave let me get
homeschooled and that's the story of how
Greg got out of high school early
um but one time I was pantsed
and instead of when people laughed in
the class
what I did was I just took off the rest
of the shorts and got on the desk and
started dancing
and you know what
I won that day you did damn way to take
away it was a way to take the power back
so that's what you got to do if you ever
get pants secondly
I think there's a couple of Heroes I
could meet
oh that go over well okay okay who is
that Mel Gibson yes that will go well
Louis CK yes that'll go even better
that'll he'll love that you know Jackie
Chan I hear
um does not treat his daughter well
because they're not fans they don't
understand they don't get it because
they're they grew up with their dad oh
they met their daughter did it yeah
that's a real sad story actually so yeah
don't don't meet your Heroes sure I feel
like my only real hero out of the
entertainment business is Johnny Depp
Johnny Depp I think you'd be kind he
seems so he seems like you hold on
especially now it's the time to meet
your Heroes Your Heroes Johnny Depp
Now's the Time uh I know my only real
hero out of the entertainment industry
or if there was someone who was I would
call my hero
that I
that was like you know someone I didn't
know but just admired only one person I
would call my hero that would be Conan
O'Brien oh he's the only one I would
call my hero
um Cone Zone it's like there's actors
I'm big fans of my whole life and I've
always really admired them but I
wouldn't call them my hero but Conan I
would call my hero sure Conan has been
an influence throughout your life yeah
it's been a reliable source for me for
news and updates uh for comedy but no I
would call yeah Conan and I think he'd
be good I think he'd be a nice guy oh
sure I get the impression you'd be
really nice dude I remember when you
made that Myspace page of Conan and then
you wrote to me as Conan saying that uh
you knew who my dad was and you thought
his work was good and then I thought I
was like
wait did I really do this yeah yeah
Myspace page and it had Conan in the
mountie in like the Canadian like bright
red mountie outfit oh my God I don't
remember doing this yeah and I think it
said uh something in the description
said like The Cone Zone is great
did you fall for it
initially
yeah I know it was so stupid I know back
then I thought wow Myspace is a small
place and Conan's here we're friends now
I got a maid in this life dude I've
fallen for worse it's okay
it's okay then you paid it Forward by
duping me
yeah that's good though that's good just
don't pants Conan when you meet him
don't fall down onto his trousers so
this guy's clearly like a George RR
Martin type yes he is or a JK Rowling or
even even a better reference
even more accurate yes uh do you think
George RR Martin gets ladies like that
he must I mean Georgia R Martin I think
is married but also it just it's got to
happen you know so some people are out
there like oh man
he knows
even if he you know resembles a hobbit
he knows ladies gather around his
grocery store scooter that's right he
didn't get on that Rascal boy he's got
that he's got that Young Frankenstein
you know uh opera singing technique you
know you just pan away and then oh
they're saying he actually can do that
oh I don't think he could sing opera I
mean that would be cool
listening to him speak I wouldn't assume
he could stick off for him but you never
know but this was a fun episode and a
great lesson to be learned can be
daunting meeting your Heroes uh I also
um I like seeing little terry really
enjoy they're really making Holt a lot
more animated this season yes
Holt is very much is is in his comfort
zone with the crew now yeah it used to
just be he's got
the he's the straight and uh no he's gay
yeah
I never used the dry humor one I've
never locked in the the innate humor of
having a gay character be the straight
man yeah you never
I don't think I I don't think I like
you know focally yeah connected those
two dots
well yeah the Boyle storyline was was
amusing it was fun it was an amusing one
yeah matter of fact I I used to
temporarily know one of the boils in the
front row it's the guy with the hair
back I was about to ask he looks so
familiar yeah we had a friend who used
to date him he's a has this whole like
vegan brand now oh it's cool we should
buy don't remember his name in this
moment but I definitely out so it's not
possible I don't remember but I've
definitely met him those times dude get
some of that vegan product uh yeah he's
uh he's nice and uh which only confirmed
for me that they shoot this in LA and no
they flew him out they were like you're
too important like a boil you look you
of all the people in this room look like
a boil I still feel like in some ways
Boyle and Gina are meant to be together
I feel like yeah maybe down the line
it'll happen you know once we get the
worst character Adrian pimento off the
show
actually there was no pimento this
episode
but yes I I think it's interesting that
they started out with that threat of
like oh man Boyle he's obsessed with her
and uh he's just always gonna keep on
trying and I like that they'd like with
Rosa
oh with Gina
there you go that's yeah I can see that
too that makes even more sense yeah you
gotta learn to listen I know I'm sorry
listening instead of projecting my own
wants and Amy with the dad's joke that
was brilliant that was delightful
brilliant joke that was yeah and then
just the way that he handled that the
birds that whole back and forth of him
berating them there's just an even more
obvious sign that he is indeed just
sexually repressed with and not
repressed but you know he's a yeah he's
got some needs he's got to tend to yeah
he's thirsty Holt I get it man he's
thirsty whole but yes I I ship Boyle and
Gina
especially after this episode
but guys listen have You Met Your Heroes
would you ever want to meet your Heroes
I'm telling you
do it because it always pans out great
leave your hero experiences in the
comments
Joe Rogan that's the hero you gotta meet
next I'll meet Elon Musk
I met Dane Cook oh how did that go
I
said uh
your I grew up listening to your albums
and I've I've gotten every single one of
them
it was really kind he's and he was like
there's no because I was like really
nervous talking to you right now he's
like don't be nervous man dude thank you
so much
and then uh hey I said you have a hot
don't be nervous you have a hot
girlfriend that's 17 year older dating
very very attractive we've got a whole
hour about that and I was even standing
by you when everyone really really did
not like you like everyone I was the
only one who liked you when no one else
liked you and he really responded kindly
to that
what nobody liked you I did I did I was
the only one you dealt waitress deserved
it
waitress the one he yelled at at the
Laugh Factory that got him kicked out of
the Laugh Factory for a while I don't
know the true story it was just like ah
he was rude to a waitress or whatever
and then they banned him for a while
I'm sure there's two sides to the story
I'm sure it was nothing and they banned
him for no reason I mean one side of the
story is that
you know
now I'm seeing her side to it I think
David Cook absolutely was in the right
that's right yeah yeah I can't see it we
need more people out there willing to
tell waitresses
whatever that was due to the fact I like
celebrity I decide celebrity yes
definitely over regular people any day
of the week well they are different they
are different and they're different they
are they are something else like Destiny
oh you're working hard ooh you're you're
trying to manage all this chaos at like
a bustling Comedy Club whatever bro I
believe God chooses people to be
idolized yes true and those are the
important people in life the famous
people yeah they are more than
us you they just know that
they are better that's one of the
Commandments is Thou shalt worship these
Idols that I picked for you I heard a
phrase the other day that I completely
forgot
whatever it was it sounds like it was
enlightened
something
when you put someone on a pedestal
you're only making less of yourself or
you're only putting yourself down or
something something like that that was
like yeah the takeaway you're like that
and yourself low yeah so you're actually
you're doing when you put someone on a
pedestal you're only degrading yourself
that's a good that's a great quote I
[Music]
you know what I take it back I don't
agree either yeah although the highest
pedestal possible really people like to
feel better than you yeah so guys uh
let's do a patreon
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo
listen dude Ricardo I am looking at your
patreon account right now oh man and
you've been a patron of ours for 10
months that is a good amount of time to
be supporting us now
you're a latino man
and Latinos can be loyal to their family
now if I consider you family
I suspect that you must never leave the
patreon page from here on out Ricardo
even if your car let's say worst case
scenario
you need to hold on your money because
you're hitting some Financial rough
times when you come back
you will be charged interest on your
patreon page so if you're like okay I'm
coming back I'm here to pledge 20 a
month you're gonna have to start off
with like a hundred dollars yeah you
understand
because that's fam if if there's one
thing I know about family and this is
what I was taught growing up at least by
my family love is conditional yeah so
you have to meet these conditional
standards that we have right exactly the
way it goes pay the family tax so yeah
if that happens or if your car just
happens to not get charged due to a
patreon error like if it's patreon's
fault you must still assume
responsibility moving forward and you
make up for the faults of patreon I hope
you get where I'm coming from and if
there's any pushback at all you will
have to increase your pledge so no
matter what happens here increasing the
pledge is usually the answer if there's
any form of a hint of negativity do you
understand what I'm getting at here
Ricardo just right now me trailing down
this thought process of a what if
scenario between us getting me a little
riled up oh so I just want to say that I
feel like you might need to increase
your pleasure yeah now I'm annoyed at
you for all these sceners because
sometimes the Mind cannot differentiate
between imagination and reality and now
my mind can't discern it no what's wrong
I believe in the imagination so way to
go thanks a lot buddy way to Dick over
your family wow who am I no I'm just
kidding you could lower your pledge
will still call you part of the family
unfortunately unfortunately we want to
but I guess blood is thicker than money
look at that we found a new way to make
it about you being Latino hey about a
good thing loyalty that's why Latino
starts with an L dude that's a positive
stereotype it is yeah Latino love
luscious
loquacious loquacious uh lugubrious
lugubrious
little little
lackadaisical
uh lick me lick
um
lollipop lollipop oh lolly lolly lolly
Martinez
okay we're good to go
[Music]